terrorism operation kill baghdadi
since then isis has directed terrorist
operations targeting americans
our allies and our partners and
countless civilians in the middle east
africa and in south asia
[ __ ] abdullah oversaw the spread of
isis-affiliated terrorist groups around
the world
after savaging communities and murdering
innocents
he was responsible for the recent brutal
attack on a prison in northeast syria
holding isis fighters
which was swiftly addressed by our brave
partners in the syrian democratic forces
he was the driving force behind the
genocide of the yasidi people in north
western iraq in 2014.
we all remember the gut-wrenching
stories mass slaughters that wiped out
entire villages
thousands of women and young girls sold
into slavery rape used as a weapon award
and thanks to the bravery of our troops
this horrible terrorist leader is no
more
our forces carried out the operation
with their signature preparation and
precision
and i directed the department of defense
to take every precaution possible to
minimize civilian casualties
knowing that this terrorist had chosen
to surround himself with families
including children we made a choice to
pursue a special forces raid at a much
greater risk than our to our own people
rather than targeting him with an
airstrike we made this choice to
minimize civilian casualties
our team is still compiling the report
but we do know
that as our troops approach to capture
the terrorists in a final act of
desperate
cowardness
he with no regard to the lives of his
own family or others in the building he
chose to blow himself up not just to the
vest but to blow up that third floor
rather than face justice for the crimes
he has committed
taking several members of his family
with him
just as his predecessor did
i'm grateful for the immense courage and
skill and determination of our u.s
forces who skillfully executed this
incredibly challenging mission
the members of our military are the
solid steel backbone of this nation
ready to fly into danger at a moment's
notice to keep our country and the
american people safe as well as our
allies
and i'm also grateful to the families of
our service members
you serve right alongside
your these soldiers and sailors marines
special forces the loved ones giving
them the strength and support they need
to do what they do
to our service members and their
families we're forever grateful for the
what you do for us and we owe you a debt
thank you
we're also aided by the essential
partnership of the syrian democratic
forces
i want to commend our dedicated
intelligence community the department of
defense and members of our national
security team throughout the government
whose meticulous and tireless work over
the course of many months ensured that
this mission succeeded
this operation
is testament to america's reach and
capability to take out terrorist threats
no matter where they try to hide
anywhere in the world
i'm determined to protect the american
people from terrorist threats and i'll
take this decisive action to protect
this country
and we'll continue working with our
close allies and partners the syrian
democratic forces the iraqi security
forces including the kurdish peshmerga
and more than 80 members of the global
coalition to keep pressure on isis to
protect our homeland
we remain vigilant we remain prepared
last night's operation
took a major terrorist leader off the
battlefield and has sent a strong
message to terrorists around the world
we will come after you and find you
once again today we continue our
unceasing effort to keep the american
people safe
and the strength and security of our
allies and partners around the world i
want to thank you all and may god bless
you and may god protect our troops i'm
heading off to new york right now i'm
late and i thank you for your time
appreciate it
eliminated sir how many u.s troops were
involved sir mr president
you